Oh, sure. Like you've never
threatened a police horse.
Actually, I have.
Well, you heard it here first.
Please like, comment,
and subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
Cut. Excellent.
Love the energy today.
Ryan, have you
been working out?
No.
Consider doing so.
Quick reminder, the all hands
pre-marketing meeting
for the marketing meeting
is today.
So, grab a quick bite,
run up to the conference room.
All hands?
Talk to me when it's all feet.
Show's over man. You can stop
Oh, thank god.
March 23 post about shitting
at a bus stop
was more popular
than the March 15th post
about shitting
at a doctor's office.
This leads us to believe
that bus stops are funnier,
while office-scapes
are inherently more sexual.
Given the levels
of engagement ...
That's right big guy.
Give them your meeting face.
You're doing great.
They think you're engaged
and nobody has any idea
you're thinking about butts.
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Reel it in.
Meeting face.
And, you can see
oval number one is small.
Oval number two
is a bit bigger.
Oval number three
is bigger still
and four is the largest oval.
So, these are ...
Yo, my name is Jordy, and
you know I like pizza.
Loving on the girls.
They say, happy to meet you.
Pizza. Pizza.
Meet you.
What rhymes with pizza?
How bout pizza?
No, that's the same word.
Wait, is Chris thinking
about butts?
Butts.
We launched our new digital
series High Priced Fish Lawyers.
It circles around a group of
lawyers who work expensive,
fish-related cases who are also
half human, half fish.
As I was saying before,
my own experience with fish ...
Devin or was it Kevin? Tevin?
Is that even a name?
Crevin.
Maybe he's Slavic?
Ugh, even if I figure
out his name,
what am I going to say?
Hey, so crazy we both come
to this hot dog stand every day.
What are you doing later?
He probably thinks I'm gross
for eating hot dogs every day,
but like (bleep) him.
He's there too.
God, he's cute.
I think Crevin is my soulmate.
Oh my god.
Is Crevin my soulmate?
Of course we have done
many graphs
relating to the effectiveness
of company meetings.
My favorite being
the pie graph.
Second favorite
is the bar graph.
Yo. My name is Jordy
and you know I like pizza.
Loving on the girls.
They say, happy to meet you.
Pizza. Pizza.
Glad to meet you.
Man, Jordan's
going to be so happy
when I tell him about this
rap song I've written for him.
I'm such a good friend.
Wait a minute.
Is Chris thinking about butts?
Butts.
I knew that I wanted to see
my pop pop
once more
before the harvest.
I was traditionally
the corn girl.
Okay, okay, okay.
Then, I ended each episode
by saying something wacky,
but still reminding people
to like and subscribe.
It's a job,
but hey, I love it.
Wow. You really are the tallest
and the smartest.
So, what's the name
of your YouTube show again?
Every Damn Day.
Wow.
Well, well, well, very
inspiring, very insightful.
You know, Nate just
keep being you.
I'm Barack Obama and I don't
think your palms are too sweaty.
The President.
As you'll see on this slide,
it was the coldest winter
on record
and I knew that I had
to pull that trigger
because my family didn't have
enough oil to heat our stove ...
I'm Jordan. I'm a fart boy.
LOL. I think Ryan is so cool,
but I'd never tell him because
that'd be bad for my image.
I'm Natasha.
I'm so weird.
I think I'll microwave some fish
and then not eat it
for some reason.
I'm Chris. I can always wear
whatever I want,
but Ryan has to change
his shirt
because that looks too much
like a swastika.
I'm Hannah, duh. I love to
(bleep)
Ryan! You've been talking
out loud this entire time.
What the (bleep)
is wrong with you?
We've been inter-monologuing
dude. Not outer.
That's when it all came
crashing down.
I could tell I lost
the respect of my coworkers,
even if I secretly
did think they were ...
Yo, we can still hear you bro.